[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room everybody
uh it's a daily nerdy news show that
keeps you in the know
um from new rockstars and here we are
live from New Roxbury Studios uh coming
off of an in-person break room yesterday
whoa at La Comic-Con limited edition
yeah we'll come back to that uh but
coming up on today's show uh across the
spider-verse updates very excited about
this some new Loki casting that's
interesting plot details for Guardians
three whoa uh
yeah you know me Guardians three oh I
didn't work there it is oh that still
sounded good uh with me here today to
discuss all of those and more we've got
Brandon Barrick I'm so happy to be here
uh and I just want to say uh in the
season finale of White Lotus Alby will
be killed whoa I'm calling it Alby will
be okay uh We've also got Jessica
Clemens is here
um two episodes behind on why Lotus
Frick uh Tommy vectility you caught up
on White Lotus uh no I'm watching a show
called White scrotus no oh damn was that
rated That's rated
and I'm Zach cuddleston I'm watching
white POTUS it's about all but one of
the presidents
uh hey let's get into some headlines oh
there it is we've got some good ones
today over the weekend and we got some
news of course last week was a big week
for trailers we got uh guardians of
galaxy vol 3 we got Indiana Jones five
the dial of Destiny we got Transformers
rise of the Beast this week apparently
we're going to get some new ones uh
we've been warned about them we haven't
gotten these trailers yet but uh Sony
they released a new image in a trailer
release date it's coming out next
Tuesday the 13th uh for Spider-Man
across the spider verse into the
spider-verse sequel
um Jessica actually is a video that's
out on the channel right now not about
that image I'm sorry I wrote my
breakdown I did my breakdown a day
before that image came out so that I
couldn't redo it but it's still good
still a great video that you should
check out and we'll have more videos on
the channel when we get that trailer for
sure yeah absolutely 100
um and then other trailers we're
expecting this one were actually
expecting expecting this week we're
getting a trailer for uh Star Wars Jedi
Survivor yes which is the sequel to the
video game Star Wars Jedi Fallen order
the calcestus joint yeah maybe he never
rested that's right you know me look at
these thumbs Zach these are video gaming
thumbs up let me tell you one game I
beat was Jedi fall in order oh I'm ready
to talk about it we're very excited for
that the game comes out in March but
we're getting a trailer I believe it
this Thursday yeah it's gonna be during
the game awards oh yeah preeminent Video
Game Awards I hear troubles a real
favorite to sweep this year but Uno
might sneak in oh yeah yeah wow after
all these years still getting nominated
number one yeah you got it oh no
um
[Laughter]
we get some casting news for Loki season
two this is interesting because Loki
season two is already wrapped filming
but you know they don't always tell us
this stuff ahead of time uh so we're
getting this kind of after the fact
Katie Dickey now that might not be a
name you recognize but she's an English
actress she was in Game of Thrones
memorably as Lisa Aaron uh who was the
lord of the veil and uh kept
breastfeeding her son
yes that woman and she was also
memorably if you were a fan of the um in
your Taylor Joy horror movie The Witch
she played Anya Taylor Joy's mom she was
great in it and another breastfeeding
scene that's uh aggressive and not good
to look ahead so we can't wait to see uh
how her breasts are involved in Loki
season two
[Applause]
so just to recap we don't know what role
she's playing she's an actress that has
a very distinctive face yes uh she's got
a great look
um so some people are speculating she
might be playing a villain a villainous
character she has kind of that natural
look um so like a a Roundup for Loki
season two potential villains well Kang
probably gotta be it's got to be in it
at least the Cameo we know there'll be
at least a statue yes it's gonna be a
presence if not a physical uh appearance
a wren Slayer still around still loyal
to one on the loose we don't know where
she is I don't think she's loyal to
anyone anymore after she got cut loose
right what she realized sorry no go
ahead no you'll please go when she
realized that they weren't who they she
caught you I was gonna say she's a
villain because she realized she was a
public school teacher wait they're
villains well no they're just underpaid
turned her evil so she's like wait a
second this was my life
you pruned me when I was a public school
teacher
um and of course we also have Miss
minutes is out there the weird uh
machine ghost uh uh oral projection
whatever and then this minute
I saw oral projection at the uh it's
blinkfest
and uh they sucked
what other performers are playing splink
Fest what what are the performers uh
there was uh unpronounceable gasp was
that Dr tooth Dr tooth in the electric
machine
actually at one point uh Fred Bundy was
there the world's best Ted Bundy
impersonator uh the world's best in
person they were great
okay
um usually we wait till later in the
show to go off the rails like that but
uh uh yeah and then you know Sylvie
we're not sure where she falls after
leading that Caesar but um hopefully
we're getting Loki season two in the
middle of next year very excited for it
we don't know anything yet you know
there's been some League set photos no
trailer or anything like that we'll be
excited to find out what uh Katie
Dickey's character is yeah they've shown
like a small trailer at d23 oh yeah I
don't think they should want a Comic-Con
or at CCA they might have showed some
footage at ccxp I'm not entirely sure on
that uh but we there could be a trailer
soon I still think Disney plus might do
a little uh here's what's coming up yeah
trailer like here's what's to look
forward to on Disney plus this year
iger's like print it out get it out what
was that famously that was the Super
Bowl trailer two years ago that had been
like two seconds of low-key and the uh
my division She-Hulk remember that
She-Hulk on the play during the was it
oh that was maybe last year it was a
minute ago but it was like they dropped
that at the yeah or earlier this year
yeah yeah that's a good one
um speaking of Marvel stuff James Gunn
uh did an interview he mentioned that he
chose mantis and Drax for the holiday
special the Guardians of Galaxy holiday
special because he felt they had been
sidelined in other MCU films featuring
The Guardians he said I think both of
them have in the past few movies that
weren't Guardians movies have been
incredibly sidelined haven't been
utilized so much to being able to really
tell their story and put their Journey
at the middle of this was important to
me now I guess like what would be their
non-guardians appearances that would be
Thor 11th under uh End Game movie War
and end game yeah we'd see them at the
end of end game but yeah and that's all
they've appeared in and to be fair to
the people who created those things
maybe not so much Thor love and thunder
they could have been utilized better
there but like Infinity war and endgame
had a lot of characters to travel yeah
but a lot of people are sign language
yes yeah but I mean drax's whole
storyline is centered around Thanos in
both the comic books and in the movies
you know he's focused on Ronin first but
at the hand of Thanos so not giving him
like as big of a moment when he finally
gets to face this guy you know I I get
that but yes you're right there were so
many characters to get through no so
many
now strangely unexplained why they did
almost nothing in 411 Thunder
felt like they made maybe only had the
Guardians for like a day or yeah we got
it two days to shoot what do you want
yeah yeah yeah
um speaking of Guardians volume three uh
mantis actor Tom clementiff
clementive I don't know but I think
you're doing come on the show Tom tell
us tell us how to say your name yes
we're not going to look there up we're
gonna not gonna look up any audio clips
of you saying it I would guess it's
Clemente
I think she's like uh Dutch and
Vietnamese or she's like a unique or so
not even close to what I said I don't
know she she's a fun combination of of
nationalities but um she was Italian oh
well maybe she's on those things she
maybe she's from ego The Living Planet
who knows um
French born in Quebec Massey okay Tommy
was the most accurate of all of us okay
good job
um but she was interviewed by Disney's
official d23 podcast and she had this to
say about the future of the Guardians of
the Galaxy she's trying to be cryptic
but she just kind of hinted at some
stuff she said it's gonna be in some
ways the end of the chapter at the uh at
the Guardians of the Galaxy family it's
not like over over but it's still it's
gonna be different after for sure now
that's interesting it's not over over so
like I don't know I interpret that
personally as like
a Guardians of the Galaxy will exist
this particular group of dragons will no
longer be well the title I think they I
think that would probably be the big
message of volume three is like the
Guardians is the title of the group The
Family is something different you know
it's Peter Quill and co uh and I I think
that they the mantle will be passed by
the end with some people staying on as
Guardians and others uh being buried or
shot out of the canyon into space
or just or go in their own way as
Fleetwood Mac would say yeah this is
that's a fun tease of our mandatory fun
later I'm not going to say anything else
but there's a mandatory fund built
around some of the things Tommy just
said that's right that segment's coming
back guys we heard your complaints we
got your calls and your threats it will
never not do a mandatory fun again
except for maybe later this week when we
don't do it I was going to say that I
agree with Tommy in the regards of like
maybe moving on I just think
which might be different and I'd like to
see this done in MCU that they hold on
to family so clearly with like uh Asgard
is not the place it's the people same
with wakanda forever it was like wakanda
forever it's the nation it's not just
the land it's the people so I want to
believe that when she's like it's not
over over I'm like if you say family's
over families still like subjective it's
like it's still like if someone passes
you guys are still family yeah so you
guys are literally spreading apart not
me you bury them I bury them out of my
mouth well that's also I love Jessica
that's such a great point you just made
because also wakanda that's a place and
a People Asgard is a people but it's
also new Asgard as a place like now the
Guardians is a place to Nowhere
um right they they are physically moored
somewhere now as they were not and that
kind of transitions uh Disney released
an official synopsis for Guardians
volume three uh which is interesting I'm
gonna read out that in in its entirety
right now in Marvel Studios Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 our beloved band of
Misfits are looking a bit different
these days after acquiring nowhere from
The Collector we find the Guardians
working to repair the extreme Damage
Done by Thanos
determined to make nowhere a safe haven
not only for themselves but for all
refugees displaced by the harsh universe
and there's more but I want to pause
that's interesting yeah like make it a
refugee Center yeah that has not been
part of the mo of the Guardians as we
know as of yet but that's a good idea I
think we talked about this briefly
um maybe last week but it's such a good
idea and that gives way to how many
other planets are Refugee spots for
different places that Thanos has just
destroyed or other plays I've destroyed
because we were talking about
um John C Reilly is a part of the oh
yeah it's like whatever those folks
bandar was destroyed before the snap
yeah that's how he got the stuff I don't
think the snap brought them back right
yeah
and even people get brought back we've
seen in several Marvel properties
notably to me is a falcon Winter Soldier
well coming back is complicated you end
up being a refugee in your own home kind
of a thing right especially if you're on
a planet that had no idea who or what
Thanos was and this event happened yes
you could have some weird religious
fundamentalism built up around this
event and the people who come back
they're like no no you guys cannot stay
here it's like what Yelena was so lucky
she came to in her friend's house that
still lived in that house
that was like the baby's getting thrown
in the air it's like when they come down
what the hell is going on
the number one babies
everywhere so many mothers and fathers
throwing their children up in the air
just as the staff happened who's my
little bundle of duh
uh now hang on it's Christmas let me
cheer you up a bit oh do we know how
they acquired it from The Collector
because I think they saved his buns
because he was in Peril oh and they
stated that I think I told him one and
they just kind of shanked uh they uh
they uh they like drifted it from yeah
or I mean I I think isn't it kind of
implied I feel like maybe
um Eric or somebody in in the video
that's on the new Rockstar channel has
implied that like he got the hell out of
there he was getting out of there around
Fan you know after Thanos came through
anyways so maybe it's just kind of like
squatters right oh because I only think
is the word the language in the Equinox
acquired which makes me think they were
like we'll help you but we want nowhere
but also movie didn't they say it didn't
nebula say since we bought it from The
Collector that's right that's what I was
he's a businessman yeah I I just you
could still be right and he could have
came back and like get this is still
mine I own this I'm mining it and they
could be like okay well we're gonna take
it off of you do they get to keep some
of his trinkets
Bucky's arm
um so uh the synopsis goes on to say it
isn't long before their attempt to
return to normal is upended by a brutal
attack from a new unknown enemy
and Peter Still reeling from the loss of
Gamora must rally his team around him to
defend the universe along with
protecting one of their own a mission if
not completed successfully could quite
possibly lead to the end of the
Guardians as we know them now there's a
couple things here we're maybe making
some assumptions a new unknown enemy I
mean there's two possibilities there
that we've seen yes the high
evolutionary uh or Adam Warlock correct
we've seen just a very brief Glimpse
we've got in Nevada morlocks kind of
looks like he's out of nowhere maybe
there's the background yeah he looks
nowhere else uh because and it is the
thumbnail we deck we have like ideas of
what it's going to be in the later
discussion but do you want to get into
it now yeah no no no okay thank you
thank you so excited stopping me and and
then
um uh
to defend along with protecting one of
their own and we're probably also
assuming that's rocket it has to be
right yeah which makes it sound like
that's the high evolutionary attacking
well well no I think you're right too I
think it's also that um rocket is you
know when you're like betrayed you're
gonna you're hot-headed right you're out
for revenge and that's been Rocket's
whole ml like I hate this guy this guy
ruined everything right he turned me
from a raccoon into this and so it's
like I think he's gonna blindly jump
into the fight and they're gonna have to
be the one to be like hey we have to
think about this we have to do it
calculatedly calculatedly yeah yeah I I
like that turn of phrase because like
honestly until I read that I hadn't
thought like I'm assume it's gonna be
rocket going after the high evolutionary
that's making it sound like the high
evolutionaries coming for Rocket kind of
come back to my planet with all the
others I created you I own you yeah I
mean this is I'm back my little path
this is like Million Dollar Baby when
your kid goes out there starts making
money now you want to
you know what if I had a dime for every
time you try to make an allusion to a
million dollars
give me a Million Dollar Baby
yeah one day or King of the Ring The
Next Day You're The Fool on the stool
okay you know last time I tried the
Million Dollar Baby threw it up
hey we real quick want a shout out
obviously we've got these great
decorations here this is holiday week I
mean how old holiday month here at the
break room but specifically this week
we're building up to we're having our
big uh holiday party this Friday live on
the show our actual new rock stars
holiday party is going to be this Friday
as well so we figured let's Let It
overlap with the break room as we're
gonna be celebrating this Friday uh live
on the break room uh and as part of that
uh Mr bechtold here Tommy is going to be
doing some bartending live on the break
we're trying to shake a shake uh he is
coming you have worked as a bartender I
have uh somewhere around and this is not
an exaggeration trying to figure it out
17 years of fire training experience oh
so yes don't try and figure out my age
and yes I did start bartending before I
was 21. yeah oh don't tell don't tell
the state of New York
um they don't care as as part of that we
think I'm dead we've actually
um we're working with this great company
iconic cocktail yeah uh Matt at that
kind of cocktail uh one of the founders
is a fan of new rockstars and we love
their products so we're working with him
uh we developed two signature cocktails
we're gonna be drinking on the air one
of which is called a Quantum Manhattan
quantumania and the classic cocktail of
Manhattan and the other now I get it
okay all right I got it and the other is
actually a mocktail it's not alcohol
it's called the um nowhere to go in
honor of Guardians volume three uh we're
gonna be making both of these and we're
gonna figure out just so good sorry yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna put out the
recipes if you order from Iconic
cocktails we're gonna use their
cranberry thyme uh mixer and their
bitter orange tonic mixer to make each
of these respectively you can if you
order it today or tomorrow this will get
to you by Friday you can drink along
with us yes you can make the exact same
cocktails we'll be drinking and let's
send us a picture of your drinks and
we'll see if you make them better than
me and if you make them better than me
I'll yield to you as is the bartender
code it's like Highlanders it can only
be one uh yes uh and it'll feel like
you're at the party uh we are big fans
of iconic cocktail they make delicious
uh handcrafted mixers that you add you
know a spirit or again you can make
these alcohol free for yourself or for
maybe family members that don't drink
and they are they come in all kinds of
different kinds and you can mix and
match with the alcohol and the mixer and
other ingredients they make this uh
ginger syrup that is oh so good uh in a
spiced honey that I really like with
bourbon when Daddy needs a little
nightcap he gets out a little spiced
honey and suburban and you coffee
drinkers sorry I know Zach I promise I
wouldn't I wouldn't preach from the
mouth the vanilla uh the vanilla flavor
that goes in with the coffee you just do
two little spoonfuls into your coffee
don't have to have any alcohol in it I'm
telling you your day is set I drink it
in the morning and it's like a little
pep talk it's like being back in high
school getting a talk from my football
coach just get in there go take on the
day here's the vanilla be iconic dang it
yes be iconic uh so you can get 20 off
your order if you want to buy these or
any other products these also make great
little holiday gifts uh head over to
iconic cocktail.com use our promo code
new rockstars and you get 20 off uh and
also check it out for they got great
drink recipes all kinds of cool stuff
over there thank you to iconic cocktail
and again uh party with us on Friday
yeah order it today what a way to
celebrate the end of the year with us
use our code get some iconic cocktails
I'll make a drink we'll drink together
we'll cheers to you we'll cheers to new
rock stars we'll cheers to the break
room yeah uh and thank you to all our
super Chatters today uh Christian
unpronounceable showing that patience is
a virtue we started not a 305 shop today
uh but we had a too much fun in L.A
Comic Con yeah all right Bucky Barnes
ATL you know wishing Tommy a happy
Victory great good job Tommy and the NFL
this weekend uh Abby and everybody said
I had the game of my life
watching I clapped it all the right time
uh Quinn talking about uh Guardians
volume three we're gonna get to some of
that conversation yes we are going to
talk about that uh make sure you like it
subscribe to this the stream let's get
into our bigger discussion today but
before we do that folks oh I have a very
special guest
you have a very special yeah I have a
very special do we have the same special
it is gonna be embarrassing if it is
wait who's your special guest you you
say it mine
is
Master attainment
mountain time
no you scooting over a little bit next
okay I'm coming in everybody oh boy
ah too many a-holes on this show now uh
in the comics we all know that Adam
Warlock he famously has a little pretty
Jewel in his head uh and it's the soul
gem what's the soul gem well it's just
the Soul Stone folks don't get too
excited they called the Infinity Stones
gems it was a whole thing but they
changed it for the MCU uh in fact when
Adam Warlock originally came in
possession of the soul gem for the first
time the soul gem tried to take over hem
it's true he tried to dominate my boy
Jim has like a Consciousness it was like
hey we gotta go take over the universe
so I got Brothers
wow I'm like was like I'm not doing this
uh but he was eventually able like to
overtake the soldier I'm gonna make it
do his bidding he was actually the most
powerful host to ever hold the soul gem
he got passed around a lot of people
touched the soul gem you gotta watch the
soul gem before you wear it folks
um but in the MCU of course we know Adam
Warlock he was teased at the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. people
were in the theater going oh I know what
that is and all the people are like what
the hell is that I don't know what that
big gold cocoon and we know that Aisha
and the sovereigns are the ones that
create Adam Warlock in the MCU he's got
something in his head right and it's not
the soul gem we assume the Soul Stone we
saw that get there there's the image
right there I wish we could zoom in on
he's got it embed it whoa stuck in there
what could this thing be
empty you have a very interesting theory
about the origins for this little Stone
in the head
yes I do um since he is a newborn uh
basically a child I think it's a puberty
pimple oh no dog
if you squeeze it does it just pop out
oh no it's just like do your hands
Sovereign
just kidding I'm sorry
um no um I think that there's a huge
chance that this could be like one of
the annulax batteries that's a song
because like when we first meet The
Sovereign the Guardians are protecting
all these anilax batteries and uh when
we first when we last leave Aisha she
says that like this is going to be the
next step of our Evolution like this is
going to be the greatest thing ever and
I think that to be to one up The
Sovereign he needs like a power source
in his um in his forehead so I think
that um yeah he's gonna be super special
because of this battery pack that put in
his head The Sovereign
batteries come in different sizes like a
double A I would hope so I mean like
they are an advanced Society so probably
okay it was would give way to it made it
seem so worthless how quick we got over
the annualized batteries in the second
Phil do you remember how quick it was it
was immediately like once ego showed up
and Blasting them all away it was like
oh okay I guess we don't really care
about it anymore but it would give way
to like how important those batteries
actually are they can power a super
individual that could just fly through
ships I'm gonna ask a dumb question they
used them at the end of the movie right
didn't they turned them into the bombs
yeah like they used so they are very
powerful yeah they can go Celestial I I
also
we know we now have kind of two
celestials in the Guardians of the
Galaxy
I also do love if if it is an annualized
battery in there how nice too because
like it's a little bit of like their
past catching up with them right right
like they are kind of Outlaws they used
to do kind of thieving for hire and
stuff like just because they're trying
to be benevolent like Refugee uh uh
coordinators doesn't mean they didn't
break bad in those first two movies okay
well and in the trailer you can see a
tentacle monster with big teeth that
looks like the one we saw from the first
movie this was that interdimensional
being that could travel between
dimensions that's what that means uh he
was going after the Batters because he
wanted it or she wanted to eat them so
maybe the Guardians have come to find
another another one of these creatures
because they cut that one open uh found
another one because they're like oh we
know this thing likes to eat these
batteries let's set it after work it's
got a battery quick interjection and
content suggestion guys when we edit
this uh episode down remember we don't
edit this one totally live for this for
for a bite-sized question what did these
things discover they like the taste of
manual ax batteries like what a specific
thing to be like oh hey this electronic
tastes great well I I will say you know
in biology right like what are we all
attracted to things that contain lots of
energy right why do we like sweet Foods
or fatty foods it's because they have
more more energy within them so maybe
this giant monster is attracted to high
energy sources like okay yes all right
that makes exactly what I think and like
we see this is why I feel like they also
appear in what if with um The Red Skull
right you think that's the tentacles
yeah I think that they're the same
creatures don't give them too much
oh that makes way more sense never mind
editors cancel that
I know it's too close to the Multiverse
of Madness but do you think that could
have been an uh a creature scent by the
high evolutionary something that was
created I have a weird feeling that this
is my weird theory that the obelisk in
Guardians 2 is going to be met is going
to meet the Guardians for the first time
in Guardians one and that he's going to
the Guardians are going to give him that
cut in the neck and Guardians three I'm
sorry Guardians three and then they're
going to send them back in time to
Guardians two and then he appears in
that portal and then they finish him off
so they feel like a weird like they
started off they cut them up and then
they send them to Guardians too all
right deal with that I think they'll be
really fun it's like I don't know if you
guys watch Doctor Who but like a river
song type scenario where like they
introduce the character and then like
they sort of like so show the origins
later I think we're the only two they're
watching my mom's okay
all right well Jessica you and
you know uh Adam more like a little bit
and you had a you had a theory that I
really liked yeah I I how he could tie
into another villain in this film
yeah
or maybe the only villain in this film
um I I do agree with the annulix
batteries it was a great Theory and I
love the idea of it and it's very
present I think though that can we go
back to the Adam Warlock photo
um yeah so that gem or whatever it is in
his head has his skin his skin like
grafted around it kind of like
cragland's little thing but mainly like
the high evolutionary that we've seen at
Comic-Con and you see how he has the
same kind of pool Where Metal and your
skin meet and it's kind of like grafting
over it I think the high evolutionary
put that in here to hijack him to mind
trick games on him because we know in
the comics that he looked he basically
takes him over under his wing and
basically like a father to Adam Warlock
so I think the situation is like the
dumb baby he is he's not gonna know
wrong from right but then when he
crosses paths with the high evolutionary
The evolutionary is going to see him as
like oh this is the ideal human being I
need to create him and work more off of
this and then puts that ship in his head
and controls him and then when cuts down
scene of him beating the [ __ ] out of
nebula because I don't think Adam
Warlock was sent to destroy nebula
because we didn't know nebula in the
second movie then right like he didn't
well Alicia didn't Alicia was like these
are the five I'm going after right well
like I think Aisha just wants to kill
the Guardians whoever wants like
whoever's on the Guardians at the time I
think Aisha doesn't care so I think that
um
yeah okay well so if we're if we go
along with that still I'm like I think
he is now being controlled by the high
evolutionary and he's just I like that
idea and that is true and like the chip
is somehow like activates him like
Bucky's weird code words
boxcars soap Irish Spring what activates
you Tommy uh me I'm activated by ag1
and G fuel uh uh that's it was the high
evolutionary responsible for Scar's
hairline
oh so I didn't laugh at this because
it's my [ __ ] money
you keep coming from our little boys
hair yo it's awful it's quite terrible
Barbara [ __ ] him up didn't do many
Justice I will say I am obsessed with
ever since we saw a crackling again in
the holiday special his fin is like
melting into his head and I'm so
concerned about it because before it
just sat on top and that was like he did
it did it look that bad with yondu I
don't know it was pretty slick with you
oh y'all knew had a better Barber that's
true he doesn't kill cragland I think
that thing in his head will I think
pregnant maybe like fused didn't so no
one could steal it or is it like he
knows how easy Franklin has like weaker
flesh and slowly the arrow is just like
burrowing it's clearly like when you
wear socks that are too tight and they
leave the rings around your ankle all
socks are too tight for me Zach I know
why you looked at me that's why I want
to thank our sponsor is Barefoot living
a Barefoot lifestyle b-e-a-r
um
I was gonna say something I got
distracted
um no no I was gonna say do you think
the high evolutionary you said you think
the high evolutionary and
um Adam Warlock are gonna go off after
this movie together yeah you don't think
he's Adam Warlock will be helping by the
end and that's what I thought I mean
there isn't obviously a chance that
Guardians like he joins the Guardians of
the Galaxy because he is a member of the
team in the comics but I feel like the
high evolutionary will take Adam Warlock
at the end and just be like we're gonna
do our own thing maybe um he's the new
guardian of counter Earth because you
know that counter Earth is um gonna be
in this movie because he was a guardian
of the counter for a while in the comics
at warlock well he also killed the
Animal Planet
I love it yeah he didn't like kill them
but he sucked them into a soul soul gem
Gamora and pip so it's like even if he
does join the team I think he'll
accidentally kill Gamora or accidentally
kill pip yeah save Adam Warlock keep him
off the Guardians for a little bit and
like put them in with the eternals or
something thing it's very super powered
individual he needs to learn operating
at a higher level right that's Guardian
I I think that we should that rich we
should monetize sending rich people to
counter Earth to hunt like bipedal
alligators like you ever wonder you ever
want to hunt an upright muskrat oh my
God you could do that
it's annulix batteries or a mind control
device that he created yeah I think the
mind control device makes sense to me
because I mean we know Adam Warlock
eventually is going to be good in the
MCU right like I mean he's supposed to
be in all these movies so or at least I
think he can be swayed at this point
yeah I think that character is very much
on the fence of like right your typical
byronic hero who is like kind of good
and maybe the protagonist sometimes but
his his what drives him and what his uh
ultimate goals are maybe aren't good for
the universe now what happens when Adam
Warlock meets white Vision I think they
just like do the lamest stuff be so good
it's gonna be so good but yeah it's
going to be very lame but it's so good
I'm gonna eat it up you get like a
Werther's original you get that white
gold swirl I think they'll honestly
probably befriend each other like how I
wanted I I kept pitching this Titania
and she holds becoming friends I think
we'd get white vision and add a more
like I actually made friends because
they're the only ones like mine and
power-wise yeah you guys get dumb
question please again uh are The
Sovereign are they organic or are they
made of machine they've they've
evolved themselves to like perfect being
but is any of that mechanical or is it
all like organic it's all organic and
like they're just like gold because they
they have evolved themselves to um
and Adam Warlock is also mostly organic
right because even though he's made in
this pod maybe that's they they say
that's how they make people right
because when Star Lord's like I want to
clap them cheeks and she's like well we
don't do that brutal stuff but maybe
I'll give it a whirl I love that she was
like I'll try it yeah yeah I just want
to think about vision then Adam Warlock
together what's your name white Vision
what's your name I'm Adam Warlock should
we kiss yes yes
I don't know why Vision knows his name
is white Vision when he finds out he's
gonna be pissed right he's gonna be like
no ambitious it's like fat Thor his name
is just Thor yeah
you can call White Vision White Vision
it is funny I call him worthless I know
but when he when he finds out it's gonna
hurt his feelings oh get over it Mr
White um Vince had his theories about
what we should name him but we settled
on white Vision because it's the most
kind of thing
uh MTV we are so thrilled to have you
here talking Guardians especially and
when you stick around for there's a
little segment that Tommy insists on
doing on this show yeah it's called
mandatory compliments what it's time for
mandatory fun
yes mandatory fun the segment's so nice
we cut it out completely last week
that's right well Tommy gets a cold and
all of a sudden mandatory fun gets
bought and sold all right but we're back
play that image of Adam Warlock
there's my graphical does he have teeth
where are his teeth we'll hold her teeth
I'm still a baby boy no teeth yeah yeah
oh he's teething maybe that's why he's
angry you ever seen a baby teething you
know what I'm talking about it's awful
all right he goes to a lot of baby
dentists
now it's time for mandatory fun
mandatory fun is where I gather my four
best friends in the whole world now last
week on a banger of a break room episode
if you haven't seen it go check it out
we ranked the likelihood of characters
fighting the dust and Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 one way or another we know not
everyone's making it out alive rip Cosmo
it's award season so I thought the
thespians of the break room could go for
the gold but I'm not talking about uh
whatever their names are The Sovereign
but uh that kind of goal I'll talk about
Oscar Gold by playing a little game we
call Oscar winning moment what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take a character
from Guardians of the Galaxy and we are
going to show their death scene the
scene that would win that actor the
Oscar
who dare go
first I can go first yeah take it away
okay okay this would be
this is how it will happen uh this is
gonna be nebula okay okay dying you have
too much hair from the ability
right now imagine I'm bald imagine yes
this will be a nebula dying
in Guardians of the Galaxy go for it
I just want to say it's been nice being
around all you people even though I hate
your guts but several years ago I found
a spot on my skin that wasn't normal and
unfortunately it is metastasized and
spread throughout my metal body that's
right I have metal skin cancer oh God
I'm dying in three
two no wait what
oh you never say one on broadcast
television what a pro to the very end
and who would have guessed nebula dying
of natural gas
amazing all right all right
how triggering is that going to be for
Peter Quill pretty ah I don't think he
cares about old man no no but I'm saying
he watched his mom yeah
I don't know guys we're sunscreen always
wears on screen and listen to that song
always wears sunscreen anyone else who
who's gonna go next I I can go next yeah
I'm gonna be dragged because like
there's a big chance that Drax could die
here okay uh okay it'll be like oh oh a
high Evolution shot me in the chest oh
you saw me a little bit in the trailer
now I'm Gonna Die For Real oh he's aware
just like my my wife and daughter oh who
died a long time ago and but like I'm
gonna I'm so happy now because I have a
new family mattress is my new daughter
and Peter's my new wife and we can't at
least once wow and it was great wow wow
bad confessions from Drax Wow
real quick before we move on I I'm
fascinated by this and to you know more
about the Guardians than anybody I know
how like we saw Drax is bulletproof
we're a holiday special yeah how can the
high evolutionary kill him yeah I think
that I mean you got shot by a couple of
pistolas yeah on Earth it was a week
weak sauce to sort of set up like a
potential death explanation for Drax
because like when he's when they're
fighting the abilisk he tries to go on
the inside and like kill him from the
inside I think it'll be like an internal
beat any type of situation where like he
gets hit but like his organs are [ __ ]
up and so it's just like oh no I'm dying
but like on the inside as it is on the
outside yes exactly it's not as hard
okay that's a great that's a great Point
okay well I'm gonna I can go next unless
you want to go next week okay sure sure
okay wait wait was did you have to leave
who were you going to be well
I don't want to tease it okay
you would mention to me who you wanted
to be okay sure who do you who are you
going to be
oh yeah uh
Tasha Tasha uh nerd baby for live shout
out yeah my bird children
yo love you guys we love you too dejana
I hope yes
who else can you see there uh Bucky
Barnes calling out the King gang of
course
sending in the couple thank you dark
rift
um Jeremy Leah or we were no it's a
Jamie Ryan Riley that's right I'm saying
earlier early Christmas love the lineup
yes anytime mt's here it's an early
Christmas lineup on that hair man okay
it looks good it looks good all right
and then hope Jackson singing happy
holidays how many kings I guess is that
that that's a very uh open-ended
question but how many kings do we see in
Loki season two maybe wow multiple Kings
in Logan season two multiples
um okay so imagine this is mantis and
she just fought Adam Warlock and she's
using all of her powers as the new
Star-Lord but it just wasn't enough and
she got punched through the chest oh
through the chest through the stomach
or chest
I could die a million times but I'd
still be happy that I told you I was
your sister oh wow because I had no
family I had no Mom and I have no father
but I had you and that's all that
matters and I'll take a million shots
through the stomach just
to save you and my family
you know what I just realized is mantis
was also spared by ego right because he
killed all of his other children so it's
like why was mantis so special
right I should watch these movies
I mean uh she showed she showed a
compassion and she was a good listener
too right it's hard to find that now yes
all right uh Zach you want to go okay
well yeah I'll go I'll be the final one
here Tammy's gonna grab a property yeah
but of course mine is uh uh I'm gonna be
Cosmo okay the space dog oh not dog here
we go oh nice yeah but of course we know
this is a ridiculous one because they're
not gonna introduce Cosmo and kill off
Cosmo okay nobody would ever do that oh
my God it's a knife
I killed that dog now how could you do
it I will go okay we're not done
I will be Adam Warlock okay Adam
warlock's gonna die I remember the baby
boy
who barely knows anything
about being your hero
but today you've taught me one day away
from the happiest day of my life which
would have been tomorrow my first
birthday oh but am I dying before then
that there is no happiness in being Adam
Warlock so Patrick before I die I'd like
to be known as Adam
all right great job everybody I think
that's it
hi hi everyone
to die on someone 's shoulder so I can
use their mind you can use both of us
sure well oh a double yes I love it okay
I'm not gonna say who I am but I think
you'll get it pretty quick okay
back in character
I
um
Groot oh
I don't get it I am Groot
oh they're sapping oh should I say I'm
great
I am Groot yeah I'm Groot she's looking
to the heavens they're Angels I've
grouped three graves in the chat
holy trees
this is like regular group this is this
is white Vision Group
get white Vision are you familiar with
the Paradox of the pine trees of fierce
that was the good one Anna did we um I
don't know if we ran a poll to say who
who did the best I think it was a
blowout
oh that was the way
but uh thank you thank you Anna uh we're
sneaking in here um check out her uh
Super Mario Brothers uh breakdowns on
the channel she might have some more
content coming out around Super Mario
Brothers soon
um thank you Mt for playing along yes
yes Mt what what can the folks uh check
out on the channel or look forward to
from you
um I have a really interesting video
coming up very soon of explaining what
that weird fleshy mess of a party was
from the Guardians 3 trailer it's very
interesting and it ties into Guardians 2
um because they said something very
interesting I just remembered I saw
flesh planted at spoink Fest as well oh
my God unless you're playing it you
should feature Tommy on the breakdown if
you can't I'll now say does it smell
yeah cause I bet it stinks does it burn
I bet it doesn't there's no stink in
space much like there's no sound
yeah you can't smell space does it smell
like steak in space no one can hear you
read like smell their birthday no I
think that's when you have a stroke
in space nobody I can hear you purr yeah
okay
no one can hear you bro and then just go
down me the photos have some stuff to
look forward to from you oh that one oh
look at my elbow that was amazing there
you go beautiful guys yes we are so
excited Jessica and I are breaking down
the Transformers rise of the beasts
trailer and let me tell you I'm not
gonna be able to disguise my excitement
much like those robots
they always have to pop up they gotta
pop out autobots
and again we might have some uh empty
mind be able to come back we might have
some other special guests all week long
leading up to our big holiday party
episode this Friday be sure to tune in
on Friday join us put on your best
holiday outfit put on an ugly sweater
and send us the pic and we'll make
yourself a non-alcoholic or alcoholic
drink from Iconic cocktails order today
to make the drink with us
yeah and instead of me Christmas gifts
thank you so much uh for watching today
thank you to mnmt for coming on the show
and uh thank you for watching and uh
have a great one bye
[Music]